Joking aside,
I was doing a play
many years ago in New York,
and, um, I came home
one night after the show.
And there was a letter
in my apartment building
from the Four Seasons Hotel.
And I read it, and it was
one of the most thoughtful,
articulate letters
I got about this whole play.
And it was signed
"Bruce Willis."
And I immediately called
my friend Stewart and said,
"Fuck you.
It's a wind-up."
And, uh, he said, "I don't know
what you're talking about.
So, I called Bruce.
I said, "Did you really
write me this letter?"
He said, "Yeah."
So we had a beer, and, um,
he says, essentially,
"You're doing the kind of work
I want to be a part of,
and whatever you're doing,
if you can put me in the mix,
I'm in, sight unseen."
And, um, I didn't think
that would really stick.
And many years later,
when I wanted to make my own
film, real passion project --
it's hard to get
those things done --
he was the first person
I called.
And he said, "I told ya,
if you ever need me, I'm in."
And, uh, we just made
this movie together
and had a beautiful time.
And I wouldn't have gotten it
made with you.
Uh, and I'm really
deeply grateful for that.
Um, I love you.
Or maybe I'm very a good actor
and I'm just acting
when I say that.
You would...
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
Um...
You wouldn't know
the difference,
and that's the reason
I love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, buddy.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Fantastic.